Hello BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us today for our 164th episode!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Are you awake?
Oh, your eyes open!
You can see us?
We don't look bluey!
I'm fuzzier than normal.
Why is it?
By the way!
Big, big claps.
Claps?
Big claps for you!
Pachi pachi!
Well, for the Ruffians joining us for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us!
But right now!
But!
Right now!
FUWAMOCO Morning will be brought to you temporarily on Mondays once a week.
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Now you know the drill, right Ruffians?
Please send your thoughts with the hashtag.
Hashtag FUWAMOCO FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
Let's go BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
What is the word?
No, no, no.
FUWAMOCO is adorable and cool!
That's good because you know it's getting hotter with the summer.
When we continue, FUWAMOCO Morning back to three times a week, you don't want Mondays anymore.
Huh?
Let's start it off on the right paw, okay, Ruffians?
BAU BAU!
I feel like it's been such a long time since the last FUWAMOCO Morning.
What comes up next, Moco-chan?
There's been a lot of exciting news happening, right?
Should we just get right to that?
No.
Moco-chan, why are you stopping like that?
I would like to say, you know, what I... Huh?
You know, you know, huh?
You know what?
You know what, Moco-chan?
There's been another Pero sighting!
OPA!
Well, we won't know until we see, huh?
What kind of nastiness has been getting up to that FUWAMOCO-chan?
Let's take a look, civil villains.
De-den!
This Pero sighting kind of warms my heart.
It's not nasty, huh?
Not nasty!
I don't know, he looks so free.
I don't know, usually solar eclipses, they're not like that.
Pero is tired.
Incandescent nastiness.
What?
Ruffians!
I mean, you say it's solar eclipse, but we thought that he's not bothering anyone.
Right, you know.
Besides, it looks like it's reaching all the planets today.
Yeah, he's even wearing some wreaths.
You know!
It looks like, you know, nothing bad happened to you.
You're all positive.
This Ruffian's positive.
More than a reason to wear sunscreen.
True, true.
There's always a reason to wear sunscreen.
Even when it's cloudy outside, you need to wear sunscreen.
Yes, wear it.
Yeah.
But... Calling Pero handsome... I think that's going too far.
Too far, Ruffians.
Yeah.
Just say, oh!
I feel... Bright!
Wow.
Yes.
Sunny!
Handsome.
BAU BAU!
You blocked the sun rays!
You know what blocks the sun rays even better?
Sunscreen!
Yep!
That's what I was gonna say!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
We have a bunch of news that we want to share with you!
You know maybe it's been just as busy as a week as FUWAMOCO is!
FUWAMOCO!
We had a big dream come true!
We just released a brand new song!
And it's actually the ending theme to a video game visual novel called Nekupara!
BAU BAU!
It's the newest, the newest Nekopara game in the series and also the final one.
Nekopara After the Rain for me.
It just came out and FUWAMOCO will be singing the ending theme!
The song is called "side by side"!
And it's written by Aiobahn, THE Aiobahn!
Aiobahn-san.
Overdose.
Internet yamero.
Amazing talented creator.
And we got to sing Aiobahn-san's song!
BAU BAU!
Yes, it is the ending theme for the game.
If you haven't tried Nekopara before, you can check it out at Volume 1.
It's on Steam, it's on Switch.
Go check out Nekopara After!
De-den!
We also played it all together, Ruffians!
From the start until the very end.
We volume one!
It got a little bit crazy.
A bit.
Ruffians, don't get any weird ideas, okay?
Ruffians!
But we're really happy.
In FUWAMOCO, we really love visual novels.
And we know Nekopara's been a series that we're big fans of.
Even though we're demon dogs, so please don't get confused.
But they let these demon dogs in to be able to sing one last song.
So we're really, really happy.
And just being able to spread our love for visual novels.
Moco-chan, you're kinda by my side there, huh?
This is also by my side, Ruffians!
We came up with the title!
We also did the spoken lines ourselves too, we wrote them ourselves.
On the spot!
But the song, you know, it's a very personal song that
It's a bit of our journey, as well as Shoko and Vanilla!
It's a very very special song, and we feel so honored to be able to sing it!
Yeah, please check it out!
It is on AyoBan's channel!
There's a very amazing MV animated!
Very nostalgic MV there, so please please go take a look at it there too!
It's a perfect song to spend summer with your family!
You know, there's the MV version, but actually...
The song is a little bit of an MV edit, so if you want to be able to hear what it sounds like in the full version, you can go check it out on streaming services as well!
Thank you, Mofu!
We hope you make a good theme to this one, Luis!
BAU BAU!
I hope we can be able to do more stuff together with the Visual Novels and share our passion for them!
As for other fun things this past week, it's been a bit busy.
It's been a busy week!
Botan-senpai!
She organized a very special event with a bunch of hololive members!
The hololive Minecraft Gold Rush Survival Event!
FUWAMOCO, we participated in it!
But for a good portion of it, I think we only did one day.
Only one day, but it was an event with Minecraft!
We have to make the
And we have different job classes that we could pick.
FUWAMOCO, we have mainly the adventure.
Moco-chan, you kind of do the minor for a bit.
Adventure, miner, craftsman, farmer.
There's lots of different things to do.
A lot of different games and events going on every single day.
Bosses, ghouls.
But,
Wow, the results are in!
And the winner who made the most money is Pekora-senpai!
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan?
Is it that surprising?
Is that that surprising?
No!
BAU BAU!
Congratulations, Pekora-senpai!
Oh, I definitely didn't kill you right away after I was announced, though.
I didn't do it on purpose!
I'm sure I was more shocked about it than Pekora-senpai was.
You sure?
I sure, boy, sure!
Nice shot.
I'm so bounded.
Why did it work that time?
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
We got 11!
That's pretty good, right?
Yeah!
Wait, how many players were there?
Oh, now we have both done!
I'm not too sure.
But 11, that's pretty good, right?
Yeah!
11 out of...
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
I was a very very good adventurer.
That's what this picture says.
It says honest adventurer.
Moco-chan, where are you there, huh?
I'm the second best adventurer!
I'm fourth again!
Here I'm fourth!
Yes!
Yeah!
So I got the adventure!
Adventure who made the most money!
Yeah!
And we had lots of fun!
We know playing together with our senpai through all the mini-games.
We had, what's it, the snakes and ladders?
Yeah, those were real good!
Yeah, together with Watame-senpai and Ririka!
That was fun.
Lots of fun!
But there's also another category that Moco-chan... You ranked in on.
Moco-chan got number 3 on the most gambling losses.
Forget that part.
It didn't happen!
And that's before we just kept on gambling away our money at the very end there!
It was broken!
It was a bug, I guarantee you!
We didn't even gamble that much, Moco-chan.
I asked Mocai-senpai, but even before I sent her my question, she was like, don't worry about it, game's over.
Hi!
I wanted to win!
But we had a bunch of fun playing together with our senpai!
Thank you Ruffians for helping us with Minecraft!
We're still learning lots, but we want to be able to play more soon!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Thank you to both our senpais for organizing it all!
And all the staff for some too!
Thank you!
I feel like there's been a lot of announcements recently.
Maybe it's been difficult to keep track of them?
I feel like maybe you missed one or two or three or more things, Ruffians.
It's been a flurry of news and a busy week.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Moco-chan, you gotta eat!
I'm gonna eat it.
I'm gonna eat the shrimp sushi.
Everybody else is not for you!
I'm gonna eat it!
And you know, I'm extra fluffy!
Nerissa there with her big pirate hat.
Why does she get the biggest one, huh?
Mine is pretty good though, too.
Yours is the tiniest one.
No it's not, it's the tiniest.
What does that say, huh?
It says nothing!
BAU BAU!
But!
It's not just a collab!
No!
There's also merchandise and there's gonna be special themed stores, decorations, exclusive merchandise, and a themed menu item!
Right!
I heard that the store is really amazing!
It's gonna be on from June 16th to now!
Until August 10th!
So we hope that you can head over there and enjoy some sushi!
And then maybe get your paws on some very exclusive merchandise as well!
There's also gonna be exclusive gifts with purchases too!
Yo ho ahoy yo.
And you saw the keychains!
Yo, ahoy yo.
Let's go to Sushi Road!
Beautiful Moco-chan!
Nice song!
Definitely buy the BAU BAU!
I'm so excited!
Please send us lots and lots of photos, okay?
Ruffians!
Please use the hashtag!
Hashtag F-U-W-A-M-O-C-O!
What hashtag is that?
FUWAMOCO!
I feel like it was really easy to say it.
Hashtag FUWAMOCO.
Done!
BAU BAU!
Wait, did she miss an O?
Did I?
BAU BAU!
Use the right hashtag, okay?
On!
We're super excited!
We hope you have a bunch of fun and have a very full tummy afterwards too.
BAU BAU!
But that's not it for announcements.
What do you mean more announcements?
I don't know, I'm already excited enough.
I can't take much more, Moco-chan.
Well make sure you hold on to your hearts, okay?
Just yesterday, there was a special 3D program that happened on the official hololive English channel.
Did you see it Moco-chan?
FUWAMOCO, we are there together.
Calli-senpai and G.G.
Ancestor.
Did you see it?
It's a big news.
But!
Well, it was a really silly time.
But the news!
News!
It's what you want to know, right?
It was announced there!
hololive English, we're gonna be having a news day concert!
A FUWAMO!
We're gonna be having a FUWAMO!
It's gonna be happening in New York City!
A radio city music hall!
The famous venue!
Not just one day of Ruffians, two days!
It's gonna be happening August 23rd and August 24th.
We're so excited!
It's huge!
And we're gonna be there together with you Ruffians!
All of hololive English!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Yeah, it's fun, super fun.
And you know, I recommend even if you are there in person to check out the streaming tickets as well because it's totally different.
You get to see really close.
Close up!
So I feel like, you know, both in person and streaming tickets are totally different.
Both very, very great experiences.
But we're really excited being able to hear your big BAU BAUs all together with us!
We're excited to hear it!
It's been more than once a year, right?
Once a year is already amazing, but more!
The experience is different, you know?
It can be new to me.
All the other Ruffians did too!
And you know that we really love concerts.
Live experiences, live concerts.
So this year, I have a goal.
If we're so lucky that we get to do another MC.
I would like to hold back on the thank yous.
I'll not say thank you.
Like, 80% less.
80%?
We only say thank you at the very end, Moco-chan.
Like, maybe we say it five times.
Why?
Because FUWAMOCO, you just end up only saying thank you!
Thank you!
Not once last year did I see you for Breaking Dimensions.
It's cute!
BAU BAU!
Why are you so thankful?
I'm just so thankful and happy and I love you!
But we're really really excited to be able to be there!
Not just here, but all of hololive English!
We're gonna do our best!
What is something else we're needed?
All of hololive English.
All of them.
Wow!
Justice!
This is hololive English -Justice-!
They also announced the 3D debut!
FUWAMOCO!
Look!
It looks good!
Nostalgic!
Right!
Justice is going to be holding the 3D showcases this August!
And fighting with Elizabeth on August 1st at 5pm!
Gigi on August 2nd at 5pm PT.
Cecilia a few days later on August 8th at 5pm PT.
And now that August 9th at 5pm PT.
Finally!
August 23rd, 24th.
All for one.
Right!
There!
Just like that!
Is it okay?
Just like that calendar for August is all full!
Is it okay if we monopolize your August?
August is ours now.
Put it in your calendar!
We have it on our calendar!
Why don't you have it in your calendar?
Put it in your calendar!
We're super excited seeing a graphic like this.
It reminds me...
AlvinSweetieDebut just about a year ago on August 2!
AlvinSweetieDebut is on your birthday!
Amazing birthday gift!
I can't wait!
We've been trying to get as much info out of them as possible, but secrets are secrets.
I'm so just as excited as you are right now!
I'll be just as beautiful today!
That's how I feel.
I feel like it was just the other day we were watching Justice Debut.
I saw today one Ruffian said, I didn't know FUWAMOCO already has 3D bodies.
Sorry, it's been a year.
It's been a year, you know, maybe there's been a month.
I've been sleeping for about a year.
Or maybe they're asleep for a year.
That's okay.
They're well-rested now.
You know, now they have even more excitement.
They think justice is gonna be defeated too!
BAU BAU!
I would notice that!
Yeah, like I said, it feels like it was just yesterday that justice debuted.
But it wasn't!
It wasn't!
It was about a year ago!
They're having their first anniversary!
BAU BAU!
Justice is having their first anniversary!
Can you believe that?
Right!
For sure!
That was fast.
Right!
Oh my gosh!
A whole year is gone!
It grew up so fast!
I know, right?
You do!
I call her!
But!
There's going to be a very special first anniversary stream on Yaeji's channel!
It's going to be happening on June 20th at 3pm PT!
And that's all we know of what's gonna happen.
It's gonna be Operation Decode.
I still remember the very first group stream after they all debuted the collab.
That was something else.
Yeah.
Now it's been a year.
I'm worried.
Why are you worried?
Is it gonna get a little bit too crazy?
Oh, too chaotic?
Chaotic?
Oh.
Operation Getting Advent.
No.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
Yeah, yeah.
Another debut.
I'm here and everything.
Yes!
BAU BAU!
I'm so happy for your justice.
Moco-chan, I feel like a proud senpai right now.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Yeah, only a few more days until our first FWC.
Exciting.
It's soon.
Time goes by fast.
Where does it go?
So many exciting things going on, so make sure you put them in your calendars, okay?
Yes, don't forget, don't forget!
Yeah, it's going to be so epic!
BAU BAU!
If you're not already, you know, awake and going and excited for the week.
Moco-chan.
Do you have something maybe?
Give us just a little bit of a... Don't give a damn!
Don't give a damn!
I think it's gonna be very, very, very, very cute and doggy, but... Hi.
Mococo seem wise.
You're being dramatic!
Hi!
Maybe Moco-chan you could give us a bit of a... Hi.
Wow.
Can I do a bit of a cry in our Pup Talk today?
A little bit more fuzzy.
Ah.
Fuzzier.
Yeah.
Okay.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
It's that time again!
It's time for another Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me!
Mococo!
Ruffians!
Have you been kinder so recently?
You know, I'm not just talking about a party, or going on a vacation, or you know, anything grandiose like that.
I'm just talking on a daily basis.
Are you drinking water?
Not coffee.
Not soda!
Water.
Are you eating properly?
Nutrition!
Vitamins!
Are you sleeping?
A full night's sleep?
Properly.
No nap.
Yeah?
No, you need to drink water, not just soda, okay?
A full night's sleep.
You know, you can't expect yourself to continue going at full steam ahead unless you make sure that you're taking care of your basic needs, okay?
You can't be angry at yourself for not being enough when you weren't even fair enough to yourself to begin with, you know?
So, make sure to take care of yourself because you're the number one person who can be kind to you.
Got it?
You're being called out?
You're being called out.
Got it, yeah?
How long is a full night?
5 to 8 hours.
We're going for fair.
Okay!
Let's all do our best!
Ganbatte deshita!
BAU BAU!
Five to eat always.
We're being fair.
Not perfection.
At least seven.
Five to eat.
FUWAMOCO!
Gambler!
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU
Gambler.
Wake up Gambler!
Wake up!
We can let Gambler sleep.
Cause it's cute.
I love the pink and blue color, they're cute!
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan, how does Gambler BAU BAU?
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
I'm so happy that you have a buddy in the camper by your side!
BAU BAU!
And next we have the day I went on a walk with you!
Where were you around this time, Ruffians?
There!
Is it a walk?
Huh?
This is your walkout!
This is not fair!
This is the best walk ever!
But you get to bring a delicious meal with you home!
Hi!
I don't know Moco-chan, I have a feeling though.
I have a feeling that this cat probably works at that place.
No, they work with me now.
Hired!
Yeah.
Yes, promoted!
Now, the boy!
It's so cute!
Moco-chan, look!
Look at how cute it is!
It's so cute!
I just, I want to be able to head directly there to this door!
To be able to smell the tommy!
That's the paws!
Look at the paws!
No, no, no, no, they're too thick.
Kiss the nose.
No, the tail, the tail, the feet.
I feel like this is a very good motivator to get going outside, huh?
Yes, cats are a good motivator for outside visits, yes!
But I'm glad that you also enjoyed the night market!
But as for a little head pat, I think you can do better than that.
We'll give him a lot more than that!
Kisses!
Get ready for kisses!
Mofo!
Look at the stripes, Moco-chan!
It's literally coffee bean color.
Next we have eye Question of the Day!
Today's Question of the Day is...
Hi FUWAMOCO!
I wanted to take this time to share my love for tabletop games, like all the different versions of Mahjong.
Do you like tabletop games?
And if you do, which one is your favorite?
I think we like tabletop games!
Fun things are fun!
We can't really say that we play them that often.
We haven't played really any tabletop games together with the Ruffians either.
We want to learn my job!
We have a FUWAMOCO!
Right!
They're gonna teach us my job!
But, uh, we also, you know, I think this counts.
We like Jenga.
Does Jenga count as a tabletop game?
I think it counts.
Jenga counts.
Tabletop game.
Jenga.
Kind of.
It does!
I like Jenga!
Not Ouija boards.
No.
Don't touch them.
FUWAMOCO!
Huh?
Tabletop?
Put it on the table, Moco-chan.
Tabletop, right?
I think we have a bunch of cards to open too.
I don't think a bunch counts.
I think it's like a bajillion.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you for all your submissions with the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
We really, really love to see what you're up to!
Let us know what kind of things are on your mind, questions you have!
Maybe doggy of a days, and you know, especially summertime, a lot of interesting things going on.
New science.
Please send them to us with the hashtag!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
Thoughts that we want to share, especially between the matches and everything too, so looking back at everything.
We hope that you'll be there to chat with us!
BAU BAU!
And for the Ruffians joining us in the archive today, your FUWAMOCO word is... BAU BAU 3.6!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today with FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Yabou!
BAU BAU!
Happy Hobi!
Caleb.
BAU BAU!
Marshall.
Itsuke.
BAU BAU!
Kamomiru.
Fish Gorilla.
BAU BAU!
Sword Caster.
Leaf Deer.
BAU BAU!
Rhyborg.
GrimCC.
BAU BAU!
Demi Itami.
We hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!